manifestation pour la paix le
désarmement à paris succès limité fin du
congrès socialiste de valence si lionel
jospin prêche une révolution tranquille
pour gagner la bataille de l'emploi
guernica à madrid la grande toile de
picasso installée au musée du prado le
tiercé aujourd'hui à longchamp vous le
13 et le 3 madame monsieur bonsoir le
pacifisme en france ne fait pas vraiment
recette le pacifisme plutôt la version
qui en étaient proposées aujourd'hui à
paris de beaubourg à la porte de pantin
par le parti communiste français le
mouvement de la praye dépoussiérer pour
l'occasion et divers mouvements qui leur
sont proches
quinze jours après bonn trois cent mille
personnes au lendemain de londres et de
rome cent cinquante mille personnes
il ya eu aujourd'hui à paris que 25
mille manifestants selon les
organisateurs 5000 selon la police il
faut dire qu'à paris la manifestation
était plutôt à sens unique contre les
bombes américaines pas nécessairement
contre les soviétiques
ce qui a évidemment découragé beaucoup
de pacifistes qui avaient préféré
s'abstenir ou qui ne se sentait pas très
à l'aise
patrick simpson jones
légalement
le cortège a quitté le plateau de
beaubourg ce matin peu après 11 heures
si certains manifestants réclamaient la
suppression simultanée de l'otan et du
pacte de varsovie la plupart réserver
leurs slogans à reggane la haine et à la
bombe à neutrons américain
et les jeunes communistes voilà pense
qu'il faut que tous les gouvernements
sans exception notamment un gouvernement
américain et le gouvernement soviétique
négocié et s'entendent pour désarmer
lancé l'intérêt de tous les peuples et
tous les jeunes du monde en même temps
les jeunes écoutez voir et ça personne
que aujourd'hui le gouvernement
américain a décidé de relancer cette
escalade dangereuse pour les peuples à l
escalade d'armement notamment en
construisant la bombe à neutrons
beaucoup de banderoles anti américaine
mais on a très peu parlé des soviétiques
ce qui n'a pas plus d'ailleurs à un
groupe de manifestants qui n'étaient pas
liées aux mouvements qui ont organisé
cette manifestation
j'ai rencontré très très peu de vrais
pacifiste dans uniquement des membres de
la cgt ou du pc et pour moi s'agit pas
de les gens qui parlent de la paix
soviétique ce n'est pas une vraie paix
ces gens ne puissent qu'ils s'entendent
si bien avait avec le parti communiste
en lieu de l'union soviétique pourquoi
est ce qu'aucune manifestation est
organisée à moscou
ils ont pourtant des liens
internationaux qui qui leur
permettraient me le font uniquement à
l'est à l'ouest
et pourtant toutes les semaines en place
trois essais se base sur l'europe de
l'ouest
il fallait en effet attendre la fin du
cortège pouvoir des banderoles contre
les missiles et les fusées des deux
grandes superpuissance
merci merci merci nous sommes contre la
fatalité de la guerre nous disons non la
guerre n'est pas fatale et nous pensons
que si les gens avaient conscience qu'il
puisse jouer un rôle qu'il puisse dire
non à la guerre si j'en ai conscience de
ça la guerre serait impossible parce que
la guerre est possible parce que les
gens de l'acsel les gens acceptent la
fatalité de la guerre or nous nous
disons tous les conflits parce qu'il y
en a il y en aura peut-être régler
autrement que par le recours aux armes
et à la guerre la journée s'est donc
terminée avec l'arrivée de monsieur
marché le cortège s'est ensuite disloqué
sans incident pour le parti communiste
ce premier grand dégagement depuis sa
semi défaite électorale est l occasion
de tester son audience sur un thème qui
le sépare de son allié socialiste
ouvertement anti neutraliste la relative
maigreur des effectifs pacifistes à
paris contre ans avec la foule qui a
manifesté pour la même cause aujourd'hui
à bruxelles
cent cinquante mille personnes selon les
organisateurs il faut dire qu'à
bruxelles plusieurs partis politiques à
commencer par les socialistes et des
organisations en tout genre s'étaient
associés pour protester à la fois contre
l'armement américain et soviétique non
aux sentiments pacifistes unilatéraux
s'est écrié aujourd'hui lionel jospin à
valence le premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste a clos le congrès de valence
en faisant adopter à la quasi unanimité
une motion unique qui détermine
désormais la ligne du parti socialiste
la ligne jospin c'est le fait du jour le
fait politique pour le changement par
une révolution tranquille appel au
rassemblement populaire avec tous
salariés chefs d'entreprise pour gagner
la bataille décisive de l'emploi après
la forte houle du début le congrès se
termine donc dans l'accalmie
ce congrès pour les socialistes est
celui de l'apprentissage de la gestion
du pouvoir
le bilan jean-michel mercurol et noël
copains
c'est dans l'unité retrouvée que les
socialistes se balançant salué la fin du
congrès certes les tendances subsistent
a remarqué lyonnaise australie l'unité
n'est pas factice
tous ont décidé maintenant de soutenir
la même ligne proposés pour deux ans il
n'y a plus ni majorité ni minorité dans
le ps toutefois son premier secrétaire a
voulu souligner l'excessive d'un propos
de michel rocard hors congrès qui
parlait de tentative honteuse pour le
marginaliser
notre texte a été adopté at il répondu
lui tom solidairement condamnés pour
deux ans à l'appliquer
bref incident pendant le discours de
lionel jospin et tourner ni j'aime
lancer aussi des délégations étrangères
l'acte d'un intrus pour crier amnistie
des prisonniers comportements
irresponsables jugé l'orateur
définir le rôle du parti par rapport au
gouvernement c'était là l'essentiel de
l'enjeu de valence lionel jospin bien
sûr a apporté sa réponse
j'entends constamment dire que le parti
doit osciller entre l'état ps il devient
alors colonisateurs ou entre le parti
godillon il devient alors colonisés ou
bien françois mitterrand siffle et ja
tour ou bien je tonnes et pierre mauroy
sans presse
et bien non sire camarades cela ne se
passe pas comme ça nous devons être et
je sais que françois mitterrand parce
que nous en avons parlé
le souhaite nous devons être les
gardiens du programme
rappelant au gouvernement ce programme
si c'est nécessaire mais se battant pour
lui dans le pays parce que c'est notre
programme le parti
le parti doit rester une force de
proposition et d'imagination
et quand on a entendu ce congrès on sait
que l'on a entendu le parti certes nous
devons tenir compte de la réalité
gouvernementale mais nous devons aussi
mener notre propre action mais il ya
quand même une difficulté une difficulté
importante comment un parti qui a été
longtemps un parti d'opposition le
devenir un parti de gouvernement
le congrès de valence a manifesté
beaucoup d'impatience et ce qui est
important c'était même l'élément
dominant du premier jour c'est que cette
impatience n'était pas seulement exprimé
par des militants de base mais qu'ils
étaient exprimées par des responsables
de haut niveau
devenu majoritaire le parti socialiste
entend teneur est un parti de combat
comme il l'était dans l'opposition et
cela pousse bien sûr un problème dans la
mesure où le gouvernement et pierre
mauroy l'a bien souligné le gouvernement
à lui le souci de l'unité nationale
ce problème devient plus aigus lorsque
l' impatience risque de rimer avec
l'intolérance
il est en effet beaucoup plus dangereux
pour un parti de gouvernement que pour
un parti d'opposition de se laisser
entraîner dans cette spirale de ce que
l'on appelle la radicalisation de la
politique
d'où le langage apaisant qui a été tenu
par pierre mauroy hier et plusieurs de
ses ministres
d'où également le langage apaisant qui
était tenue est tout à l'heure la fin du
congrès par lionel jospin qui disait
nous ne devons pas nous complaire dans
la dramatisation
comment continuer à incarner la force
tranquille avec un équipage fougueuse
tel est le problème qui se pose au
gouvernement et au parti socialiste
à moins tout simplement que la fougue
des uns ne met mieux en relief la
tranquillité des autres
en tout cas le congrès de valence le
mérite de poser clairement ce problème à
défaut peut-être de l'avoir déjà résolu
cet appel à la modération en tout cas ce
rappel à ce que doit être le rôle d'un
parti majoritaire au pouvoir c'est le
chef de l'état lui même qui l'a exprimé
ce matin dès son retour de cancun
bernard pradines on a demandé au
président mitterrand sa réaction aux
divers épisodes qui ont émaillé les
débats très tendu de l'assemblée
nationale au sujet des nationalisations
finalement chacun joue son rôle tout
cela est normal dit en substance le chef
de l'état écoutons le
peut-être cette opposition mais tel un
acharnement qui me fini par tomber dans
les jeux de la procédure
mes photos si cette procédure est
régulière il faut que la majorité elle
par la qualité de ses arguments je crois
que il a cette qualité par sa ténacité
par son sang-froid parviennent à faire
voter les lois nécessaires à la
république nécessaires à la république
pour que nous puissions disposer de
ligue 2 d'un secteur national élargi
lesquels il sera possible de planifier
de développer notre économie de d'éviter
une division internationale du travail
qui dépendent des autres et dépendent
des grandes sociétés multinationales et
aussi afin de réaliser ce que je crois
une nécessaire la restructuration
industrielle trop longtemps attendu car
ça fait quinze ans qu'elle n'a pas été
entreprises
bon alors je crois qu'il faut faire
jouer le jeu parlementaire pleinement et
si j'ai entendu dire qu'il y ait là il y
avait eu des ics la chine trop si
certains trouvent l'opposition j'ai vu
ma main tolérante
je crois qu'il faut que l'opposition
s'habitue être opposition et je n'ai pas
l'habitude de ça faisait 25 23 sans
qu'il se comportait comme une majorité
elles mènent 13-1 tolérante et il faut
que la majorité s'habitue et majorité
est là elle aussi 23 ans d'opposition
ont alors tout cela se mettra à sonner
en place le conflit 1 renault
billancourt les négociations ont repris
cet après midi entre la direction et
l'intersyndicale au coeur des
discussions les garanties minimales de
carrière pour les os en cas de nouvel
échec l'intersyndicale décidera demain
matin de la poursuite de son action à
l'étranger aujourd'hui l'événement le
plus symbolique a été en israël la
manifestation qui réunit plusieurs
dizaines
milliers de personnes en hommage au
président sadate la manifestation a eu
lieu sur une place de tel aviv rebaptisé
au nom du président égyptien assassiné
elle était organisée par le pacifiste
israélien a bein datant cette
manifestation coïncide avec la visite en
israël du vice premier ministre égyptien
kamal hassan ali une visite qui sert de
test aux relations israélo égyptiennes
au caire le nouveau président égyptien
moubarak a reçu le chef de l'opposition
israélienne shimon peres qui s'est dit
tout à fait rassuré sur la poursuite du
processus de paix grande première dans
la justice italienne
un terroriste repenti de prima linea qui
avait pourtant participé à l'assassinât
de deux carabiniers n'a pas été condamné
à la prison à vie
c'est la première application de la
nouvelle législation italienne destinée
à encourager la collaboration sinon la
délation et la défection des terroristes
dominique tiers cet homme c'est michel
viscardi en août 79 il participe un
hold-up qu au cours duquel deux
carabiniers sont abattus le butin de
cette agression devait servir à
alimenter les caisses du groupe
terroriste prima linea mais parce qu'il
a accepté de collaborer activement avec
les magistrats les jurés italiens ont
allégé sa peine il purgera 13 ans tandis
que ses trois co accusés sont condamnés
à la prison à vie
c'est la première fois que les tribunaux
italiens encourage aussi ouvertement un
repenti michel viscardi et est à ce
titre un puits de renseignement
puisqu'il fit aux magistrats le récit de
toutes les actions de prima linea
notamment celui des attentats contre
deux juges de milan avec le nom des
participants
son compagnon de détention roberto
vittel l'irpp andy lui aussi ne
bénéficient pas de la même clémence il a
refusé de donner des noms il restera à
vie derrière les barreaux vis car le nul
c'est presque livre
dans la sonnette figuet il ya cent ans
tout juste laissé à malaga en espagne
pablo picasso
en 1937 il signait avec guernica le plus
célèbre cri de haine au nazisme qui
avait rasé cette année là la ville
sacrée des basques pour picasso
l'espagne franquiste était devenu
maudite et ses toiles la plus célèbre du
peintre devenait l'un des joyaux de
musée d'art moderne de new york
guernica ne retournera en espagne
qu'avec la démocratie avait dit picasso
c'est chose faite depuis ce matin les
espagnols peuvent enfin admirer l'oeuvre
chez eux au musée du prado à madrid
ils s'y sont pressées depuis ce matin
notre dossier du jour maintenant la
foire du livre de francfort depuis qu'il
a fermé ses portes au début de la
semaine les éditeurs du monde entier qui
se rassemblent tous les ans à francfort
dans une forte odeur de saucisse font
leur compte pour eux c'est l'occasion de
faire le point du marché du livre dans
le monde cette année il est morose et
pour le livre français en particulier la
situation n'est pas brillante
monique attenant ce paquet a coûté 90
tiré à 65 exemple
ce livre qui n'existe pas encore cet
ouvrage à l'état de maquette sur
l'histoire du papier monnaie
c'est un peu le symbole de cette 33e
foire de francfort
mais ça donne la qualité du papier
l'épaisseur définitive du livre
cet ouvrage qui coûte trop cher à
réaliser par un seul éditeur a besoin de
leur participation d'investisseurs
étrangers
ce n'est qu'à ce seul prix qu'il verra
le jour car c'est bien de cela qu'il
s'agit
prix de vente prix d'achat tel est
l'essentiel des conversations entendues
dans les allées de la fois parfois même
jusqu'à en oublier le contenu du livre
francfort s'est chaque année 5425
éditeurs venus du monde entier faire
leur marché de livres étrangers
mais aujourd'hui il faut l'avouer le
marché plutôt calme pour ne pas dire
morose les éditeurs de chaque pays
achètent moins sont plus vigilants car
ils doivent déjà faire face aux crises
de leur marché intérieur
exemple l'allemagne jusqu'à présent
épargnés se voit touchée à son tour par
une surproduction de livres notamment de
livres de poche qui met en péril de
nombreux éditeurs même si cet homme le
numéro un mondial de l'édition reinhard
mohn propriétaire de l'empiré
bertelsmann se porte bien
cette année il va investir 40 2 millions
de francs dans ses filiales anglaises et
portugaise côté français même problème
de surproduction les éditeurs avoue ne
pas vendre beaucoup et être pour la
plupart à la recherche du best-seller
qui permettra de les sauver
financièrement des livres à grand tirage
que les américains grands gagnants de
cette fois sont toujours les seuls à
savoir fabriquer les écrivains français
on a perdu l'art de raconter les
éleveurs français sont
porter vers la psychologie vers l'art de
couper les cheveux en quatre les
américains racontent une histoire
passionnante et c'est ce qui explique
aussi que dans l'autre sens à dire de la
france vers les états unis la
littérature française est de moins en
moins exportable que je traduis se
traduit chaque année environ 20 livres
américains et 10 ont tous les trois ans
j'arrive à vendre un lit france et aux
états unis
si le roman français intéresse moins les
américains apprécient toujours nos
productions décès philosophique et
d'histoire quoi qu'on trouve dans les
essais les documents de livres qui sont
comment dirais-je plus plus accessible
aux américains qui leur semble plus
important lévi strauss
piaget si vous l'acceptez commentaires
français et un tas de bernard henri lévy
ata ii de dub écrivain qui n'écrit pas
le roman l'intérêt de francfort ou de
lundi saucisses reste avant tout de
prendre la température de l'édition un
secteur qui chaque année doit se
réajuster à la demande et qui assiste de
plus en plus au triomphe des livres
d'art des livres de photos plus facile à
exporter triomphe de l'image
omniprésente
parfois au détriment de l'écriture et de
la réflexion élections en demain à
l'ordre du nouveau président de la
conférence épiscopale les 120 évêques
membres de cette assemblée devront
trouver un successeur à monseigneur
etchegaray qui ne peut pas se
représenter plus de 30 évêques dans
l'année à venir seront atteints par la
limite d'âge beaucoup d'entre eux iront
dans des maisons de retraite
mais la deux a choisi une formule plus
originales jean-claude d'arrigo ce
prêtre s'appelle louis ferran il y à un
encore il était archevêque de tous à 75
ans il a présenté sa démission au pape
puis il sans plus tarder il s'est rendu
chez un de ses amis évêques et et lui a
demandé une petite paroisse pour
service jusqu'au bout un apprentissage
que je dois faire attention à ma
première année j'avais été vicaire
professeur supérieur du séminaire
évêques archevêques jamais été curé
alors je commence c'est difficile ce
n'est pas très facile pour moi mais sur
ce que de mon choix jamais je n'aurais
pensé que nous aurions un architecte
comme prêtre résidant alors je me suis
dit c'est une blague qu'on fait c'est
pas possible
alors comment est-ce qu'il est votre
curé archevêque et bien il est comme un
prêtre de campagne le prêtre que nous
désirions un prêtre simple très près des
gens faut vous savez pas de différence
qu'ils soient achevées
non pas du tout on sent très à l'aise
avec lui pas du tout voir
au début j'étais un petit peu intimidé
mais il y à un pic de temps en temps ils
plaisantent toujours il est prêt on
avait tout l'alliance première qu'on
appelle l'ancien testament que vous
rappelez ca annuel
bon et puis maintenant je m'aperçois
qu'un curé de campagne
on a beaucoup de choses à faire il a
beaucoup d'activités à exercer même avec
750 habitants pour les connaître les sa
première chose à faire c'est de les
connaître
si on veut bien les aimer et puis de les
connaître à leurs diversités cas dans un
petit village un petit hameau une petite
cité si vous voulez comme ici il y a
plusieurs espèces de résidents et il
faut donc les connaître les uns des
autres et ce n'est pas très facile alors
monseigneur où monsieur le curé comme on
préfère c'est me courageusement à
l'oeuvre faisant l'expérience des
satisfactions mais aussi de la solitude
et des contraintes matérielles du curé
de 1981 personnes à la maison pour
l'aider des comptes et du nettoyage à
faire autant de choses que l'archevêque
n'avait connu que de très loin
elle m'ennuie pas travailler comme ça
c'est bon que mes confrères autour de
moi je suis bien obligé d'en faire
autant mais il faut reconnaître que ça
peut prendre beaucoup de temps pour le
ministre sur le ministère
c'est vrai louis ferran ne semble pas
regretter son choix retourner à la base
a du bon dit il
cela permet de se rendre compte de bien
des choses à ma question ne serait-il
pas opportun que d'autres évêques face
comme vous le temps venu il a répondu
avec un clin d'oeil
ce serait une chance pour beaucoup
d'une retraite à l'autre les beaux-arts
fleurissent parfois dans les hospices et
réchauffe la vie de ceux qui n'avaient
pas toujours trouvé dans la vie
l'occasion de dans la vie active
l'occasion de développer leurs dons
notre émission c'est la vie fera
d'ailleurs tout au long de la semaine
prochaine une série de reportages sur la
condition dans les auspices de france
avec monique karr à voyons comment à
l'hospice d'ivry les retraités trompent
leur ennui
dans ce lieu où chaque jour se
ressemblent dans une monotonie éternel
les murs neufs au vieux n'ont plus
d'importance et pour sortir cet ennui
qui crée des grabataires l'hôpital
charles foix d'ivry en pleine rénovation
d'ailleurs à lancer une expérience un
salon de coiffure où l'on maintient une
image soignée du corps une salle de
musique aussi où l'on aime venir rêver
un peu
et surtout au coeur même des ados spis
les ateliers de peinture et de sculpture
ou de grand talent se sont déjà révélés
que j'étais désolé désespéré vu ma foi
ça va changer les idées quoi vous avez
des idées très noir ah oui il y avait de
quoi
pourquoi parce qu'il pouvait tout perdre
je vois qu'il ya beaucoup de prénoms sur
votre tableau alors ça représente qui
est datée mes enfants mes filles mes
petits-enfants mon nom ici bien et puis
mon mari est décédé et voyant passer mes
filles les pigeons sans qui on
s'ennuyait l'hôpital st bonnet g n'est
plus bien comment samuel environ 100
mais ce que je voudrais vous sortir plus
souvent savait que 80 ans guen ne
servait plus souvent alors là je serais
content si bien que je reste ici
correspond certes ça fait quatre ans que
je viens travailler à ma propre peinture
dans cet atelier
et je ne suis pas un enseignant c'est à
dire je ne viens pas pour apprendre à
peindre mais avant tout pour voulait
favoriser l'expression des personnes qui
viennent ici tu crois que justement le
plus important ça a été de découvrir que
des gens qui n'avaient pas peint durant
leur vie comme c'est souvent cas ici
pouvait se mettre à faire des dessins
des peintures sur une toile ou à
sculpter sans apprendre de recettes très
important de préciser que si tous
vieilli l'imaginaire ne vieillit pas les
personnes âgées représentent un héritage
et se d'héritage il peut se perdre si
nous ne prenons pas le temps de
d'écouter la personne âgée il faut que
l'adulte
les jeunes viennent épauler l'effort de
mesure et de ces handicapés sont
actuellement
un temps fut ce qu'attend et fait mourir
notre histoire du jour est une histoire
édifiante pour les amateurs de petites
annonces en août dernier paraissait dans
plusieurs journaux parisiens
une annonce particulièrement elle les
chante en prime un départ pour le brésil
ce week end
si vous avez répondu à cette annonce
yves si vous n'êtes pas parti
jean-claude allanic vous explique
pourquoi quand une jeune fille rêve de
cinéma etc une petite annonce lui
propose de tourner un sim au brésil avec
un salaire de 10 mille dollars
il ya de quoi éveiller bien des
vocations qu en outre l'agent recruteur
donne rendez vous aux candidates pour le
départ à 10 heures du matin au stand de
la compagnie aérienne brésilienne
le rêve commence à prendre forme mais
hélas c'est aussi à l'aéroport que ce
rêve a pris fin car si les figurantes
était bien là il a fallu se rendre à
l'évidence cette petite annonce était
une escroquerie
j'avais posé ma candidature
moi dans le mois d'août j'ai une réponse
favorable on me disait coordination
était revenu que le tournage duré trois
mois au mois d'octobre décembre
octobre novembre décembre et qu'il ce
film se passer s'est déroulé durant le
carnaval de rio alors que le carnaval de
rio et une moitié vrillé c'était un film
romanesque ne comportant aucune séquence
monographique mais on our en revanche je
me demandais 350 francs pour
l'établissement d'un contrat de travail
du président arrêtez vous viennent
on a mis un peu la puce à l'oreille
parce que on n'a jamais demandé d'argent
pour établir un contrat de travail
en outre les rendez vous
à 10 heures au stand de la marègue à
roissy alors qu' il n'y a pas de temps
le var égard voici donc je me trouve ce
matin
aux sports de paris orly et bien
évidemment il n'y a personne
personne en effet à l'exception de
quelques figurante qui après avoir
attendu en vain à roissy était venu
finalement à orly mais sans grand espoir
vous avez envoyé le 350 francs
mais aucun espoir de les récupérer quant
au sens personnellement je vais à la
pêche
ça marche devant
à aucun moment vous a vu un
moi je n'ai d'autre part depuis hier des
bus depuis dès le début j'ai fait des
pieds et des mains pour savoir pas mal
de soi c'est pour ça que ça arrive et le
fit plus tôt et tout ça paraissait pas
c'était trop beau pour être vrai c'est
tout vous avez fait ce que vous pouvez
faire pour empêcher que ce genre de
petites annonces soient publiées dans la
presse et que les gens se fassent piéger
j'allais dire si notre travail quotidien
nous faisons un effort ciblé de
prévention pour essayer avant diffusion
de ce nul de ce genre de messages de
bloquer ces annonces publicitaires et
ses devoirs qui est derrière
mais dès que l'annoncé a été diffusé que
là le corps social les gens les lecteurs
en plus conscience de des annonces
il faut là qu'on fasse vite un travail
de contrôle et vérification nous devons
vérifier que la société existe bien
qu'il y ait un contrat de travail qu'il
ya bien j'allais dire une réalité de
lens ne portent pas si vous voulez
empêcher les sociétés tout à fait
sérieuse de faire ce genre de
proposition escroqué de 350 francs ces
jeunes filles iront sans doute perdu
quelques illusions
combien sont-elles dans ce cas nul ne le
sait hormis l'escroc qui lui a fait la
valise parlons aux chevaux maintenant il
y avait une épreuve importante
aujourd'hui à longchamp le prix royal
oak qui a été remporté par art ross une
surprise goce draveurs la gagnante de
l'arc de triomphe a été battu mais le
kerser se jouait sur le prix du nabob
pierrette brès au début de la ligne
droite si boy est encore montée du
peloton suivi de présentant qui vit à la
pomme fait livrer les amis sont sur la
même ligne avec mary sectorise qu'au
long de la corde à mi-ligne droite si
boy est attaqué par l'adami qui est à la
lutte avec ses livres présentant mexa
est belle si le poteau d'arrivée était
un trimestre si boy présentant folon
pour céder devant c'est du vent mais
regardez bien ce qui va se passer tous
les chevaux sont en pleine piste côté
corde si boy présentant ses libres à
l'extérieur moonbeam mis ce matin à pois
chiches viennent très très fort mais
moonbeam se dérobe à gauche entraînant
avec lui pois chiche
nous allons revoir l'incident de face
regardez le troisième sera l'avant
dernier il penche sur nice matin et
watch me ce matin revient en dedans en
perdant des longueurs philippe meyer
l'apprenti jock et continuer à frapper
loubine à droite alors qu'il se dérobe à
gauche il aurait dû changer sa cravache
demain pour redresser son cheval mais il
continue son erreur emmenant avec lui
pois chiche
malgré cette grosse faute mombin et
seulement rétrogradé à la 2e place
arrivé du tiercé pois chiches moonbeam
félibre 12 13 3 qui rapportent dans
l'ordre pour 5 francs 8 milles 7 francs
50 et dans un ordre différent 1600
francs 50 le temps de maladie un temps
de saison sur la majeure partie de la
france frais et instable avec des
éclaircies des passages nuageux et des
averses
il neigera au dessus de 800 à 1000
mètres il y aura du soleil seulement
dans le midi mais avec du vent lagence
pour les économies d'énergie vous
déconseille donc le chauffage si vous
habitez la côte d'azur et la corse
partout ailleurs vous avez intérêt à
chauffer un peu voilà je vous rappelle
les titres de cette édition succès
plutôt limitée pour la manifestation
pacifiste de paris fin du congrès
socialiste de valence lionel jospin
prêche la révolution tranquille le
tiercé la combinaison gagnante le 12 le
13 et le 3 merci d'avoir suivi ce
journal à 23h35 dernière édition avec
hervé claude de ma vie dit vous avez
rendez vous avec philippe labro qui
examinera avec le professeur alfred
grosser la situation de l'europe sous
les fusées demain soir patrick poivre
d'arvor
je vous retrouve dans une semaine
bonsoir